I'm gonna be sitting down with Tommy
Robinson this week to say Tommy's a
controversial figure would be putting it
mildly you only have to glance at his
Twitter mentions to see how some see him
as a modern-day hero defending Western
society while others see him as a racist
thug thankfully I don't get all my
information from Twitter and neither
should you
Tommy is the co-founder of the English
Defence League a movement that opposes
Islamism and Sharia law in the UK he
left the EDL a few years ago after
connecting with Majin Wozzeck William
foundation because he felt the EDL had
become too extreme now Tommy is part of
pegida UK a subset of the bigger
European pagina movement which has the
stated goal of preventing the
islamification of our countries
basically Tommy thinks that the UK and
now all of Europe are in route to
becoming Islamic nations Tommy reached
out to me about two months ago to see
about being a guest on the show before I
said yes I actually had to do a bit of
soul-searching as you guys know I'm
beyond fed up with the regressive left
labeling of everyone a bigot or a racist
but in Tommy's case are they actually
right and if the regressives are why
should I even talk to someone with
racist views there's no doubt Tommy
spends most of his time talking about
the dangers of Islam he certainly isn't
hiding that but are his motives actually
based in bigotry it wasn't just those
questions that had me unsure whether to
talk to him though there was actually
something else at work and something
that really exposes the rot that the
regressives are causing in our society
part of me was actually afraid that if I
spoke to Tommy regardless of whether he
really is a bigot or not that I also
would be labeled a bigot let me repeat
that I feared that just by having a
conversation with someone just by
hearing their views on this show as I do
every week that I would then get one of
those awful labels that people throw
around thrown on me after a couple days
of thinking about it I realized that not
only did I have to do the interview with
Tommy but my fear was the exact reason
that I had to do it the chilling effect
that words like bigoted and racist have
are not just on the person at who they
are aimed but they're also used to stop
other people from talking to them the
less we talk the more the authoritarians
can move in with easy answers once I
really wrap myself around that it was a
no-brainer like all my guests all at
Tommy's ideas be heard and you the
audience will be the judge
ironically if the left had been more
honest about the dangers of Islamism all
along I would feel less of a need to
have conversations like this but they
refused to so here we are if his ideas
are good then let them spread if they
aren't then let them be beat by better
ideas as my former guest Douglas Murray
said on Sam Harris's podcast a few weeks
ago it's too late to be willing to be
blackmailed by people who are
fundamentally insincere in their insults
that's exactly how I feel about labels
or pretty much any of the other nonsense
coming from people who would rather
stifle debate than have it this past
week and i rewatch one of my all-time
favorite movies V for Vendetta in these
powerful speech to London he says and
where once you had the freedom to object
to think and speak as you saw fit you
now have censors and systems of
surveillance coercing your conformity
and soliciting your submission how did
this happen who's to blame well
certainly there are those more
responsible than others and they will be
held accountable but again truth be told
if you're looking for the guilty you
need only look in the mirror I think
it's getting high time that we all look
in the mirror and decide what we believe
[Music]